la oficina de la onu para los derechos
humanos concluyó que es irina bucle fue
asesinada por las fuerzas israelíes y no
por disparos indiscriminados de
milicianos palestinos como en un inicio
habían señalado las autoridades de
israel así lo ha firmado desde ginebra
la portavoz raviña shamdasani basándose
en investigadores independientes que se
desplazaron hasta la ciudad de yenín
analizaron grabaciones y fotografías y
entrevistaron a testigos asimismo
tuvieron en cuenta los informes del
ejército de israel y de la fiscalía
general palestina la portavoz de la
oficina que dirige la alta comisionada
michelle bachelet señaló que todas las
informaciones recopiladas apuntan a que
no hubo actividad armada de grupos
palestinos en el momento del crimen de
la reportera palestino estadounidense
además tildó de profundamente
preocupante que las autoridades de
israel no hayan abierto una
investigación penal y es que recordemos
que por ahora las fuerzas israelíes las
llamadas y de efe han realizado una
investigación interna de la cual no han
divulgado los resultados en este sentido
la oficina de bachelet reclamó a israel
que también investigue todos los demás
asesinatos
graves cometidos por las fuerzas
israelíes en gaza y cisjordania ocupada
la vocera recordó que sólo desde inicios
de año el organismo ha contabilizado el
asesinato de 58 palestinos entre ellos
13 niños por parte de las fuerzas
israelíes en cisjordania al momento del
crimen irina bucle una referente del
periodismo árabe se encontraba cubriendo
una redada israelí en el campo de
refugiados de yenín para la cadena su
cadena al yazira su funeral congregó
aquí en jerusalén a miles de personas y
desde entonces familiares y colegas han
multiplicado en los reclamos de justicia